[Music]
hello I'm Francisca and making a fitting
place for birds with plastic cutlery is
quite easy I will show you how you can
do it yourself you need a plate and a
bowl of hot plastics such as melamine a
20 centimeter long threaded rod which
you can get from a DIY shop for washes
for nook and a drill drill a hole in the
center of the bowl press only lies you
go to drill and take great care because
the plastic can split now do the same
with a plate getting just as much can
[Music]
take the threaded rod and push it
through the hole in the bowl fix the rod
from above and below with a washer and
nut you can also use classic washers
which are especially suitable for
melamine
[Music]
and this is how the whole thing looks
now take a washer and nut and screw it
to the top end of the rod put the plate
upside down on top of it fix it with
another nut and washer and your bird
feeder is ready if you'd prefer to hang
it up and not stand it screw another nut
onto the upper part of the threaded rod
and fit the car to it now all you need
is bird food and the birds can come and
if you find the roof top boring you can
paint it with colorful strips or dots
just remember to use waterproof paint